[Music]
MILF Island you watched it yet no but
I'm curious is it real
yeah and it's out right now TLC I think
so
can we just pop on the trailer for this
[Music]
one who has given me some curveball I
think it's my time to find love
I was married for 14 years I want to get
a chance to do me a little young men
have much more energy they think out of
the box I want okay
I love this already
can I just comment on
the sentence young men have more energy
oh yeah that's not an observation
what do you mean that's just
biologically yeah true yeah you know
yeah so just a fact yeah just stating a
fact yeah yeah but I I just think it's
funny when people say it's not it's not
specific to that phrase I just think
it's funny when people say stuff like
that yeah the biggest thing that really
now grinds my gears
is if I'm in public and I hear people
talking about sports or just some
situation where they describe two
outcomes and the outcomes are painfully
obvious you know
well you know they're either going to
win or this and then they might lose
no [ __ ] what she should have said is
I want an 18 year old dick yeah
I want a guy whose dick feels like it's
18. yeah exactly
hi hey I'm Derek I am Avid Starcraft 2
player and I'm also on trt
okay Derek JK energy they think out of
the box I want that especially in the
bedroom
don't you want them to think inside the
box in the bedroom
thank you that was good man thank you so
much I like that one
amazing beautiful mansion here in Mexico
what are you doing why are you
why are you [ __ ] me I'm just thinking
outside the box
there's more than the box I mean there's
tits
there's arms think when I'm inside the
Box though
holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right that one got me
that's not funny that's hilarious
that is so funny how long were you in
there for
you that's why I asked you guys to come
oh my God way to think Inside the Box
guys
nice
to think Inside the Box
I'm gonna I'm just gonna be like on the
edge of my seat now because it's like
connected to the door so someone could
crawl and not and we wouldn't see
crawl in here we wouldn't see that thing
would Shake around you'd be all right I
already know what the comments are gonna
be ready
you guys are so mean to Cody you're
always bullying him for liking cocaine
and being non-neurotypical now you're
gonna scare him all the time
so I mean it is kind of [ __ ] up
to scare you um yes I'm easily scared
it's kind of [ __ ] up
guys it's not nice that you scare Cody
you know he has a small brain he can't
handle it
there we go just making sure
all right Grinch just know that I'm
gonna throw that [ __ ] moose at that
box yeah I know
if there's one more break
I have an extremely high libido is that
too much Shane I have an extremely high
libido should I just said hi libido
I'm just looking to have fun
[Music]
here we go
what the hell
it just got real what
what's wrong with them why weren't they
stole all of their sons
I think it is that's what yeah I guess
is yeah
no way dude if that's a Twist genius
genius but [ __ ] up Derek what are you
doing here I'm here to [ __ ] a MILF uh I
got bored of Starcraft and uh mom I've
been [ __ ] your friends Loki for like
two years okay sorry I had to find out
this way but dude that's the funniest
thing to me about gen Z is the the lingo
yeah nice dude
damn
he got over me
I care her she said
okay okay yeah
she's like 20 20 away behind us
all right later dude
really was that bad huh yeah Ryan just
left Ryan's like yes
we don't care you're the middle of a job
in the afternoon
yeah oh you know what actually I haven't
eaten lunch either
[Laughter]
I haven't eaten lunch either
I'll just do it on the show
this is a little [ __ ] distraction
yeah yeah guys are distracting yeah
that's from the fact that someone's in
there oh
[Music]
is he just crawls out
[Laughter]
oh man
after doing that is he's like I'm not
going back in that box
[Laughter]
she could still be in there
[Laughter]
Ryan I don't want to hear you laughing
go eat
You're Gonna Leave the [ __ ] party
hungry
okay dude
yeah no it's actually that's exactly how
you said it don't try to act like you're
a big boy now
they might tell me who is I'm so hungry
I'm gonna eat this you would prioritize
lunch
over this
the last episode of the Year seriously
[ __ ] what are you eating
hmm you left for a salad for a [ __ ]
salad which is not even food good yeah
that's what that eats salad yeah dude
that's what that deer eats
make sure Izzy's on the box
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
yeah so we're gonna need new carpet
this is gonna have mold right here
if you're listening on audio the set is
completely clean and we're having a
I don't know what bad joke I'm trying to
make our knife listen on audio you're
missing out that's all I'm trying to say
anyways yeah dude I'm just thinking
about
gen Z
like
early 20s dudes talking to these
moms like so tell me about yourself like
well
um
I left
play a lot of Rocket League honestly
[ __ ] goaded at that yeah you know my
whole life is just like a dub honestly
yeah
what you ever watch movies
yeah I love movies yeah my life is kind
of like that
what what yeah yeah like have you ever
seen like um Wolf of Wall Street yeah
like that's my life before he goes to
prison
you think it's their sons
sorry that's just that dude getting head
[ __ ] your neck is so coated
[ __ ] your [ __ ] as goaded as [ __ ]
oh my [ __ ] god dude all your neck is
[ __ ] yo W top yeah
yo this top is a [ __ ] dub big dub
chat what do you think dub top or Nah
dubs in the chat for this [ __ ] oh God
foreign
goats down there
so good that's so good and I'm about to
go I'm about to go foreign
[Laughter]
like literally a goat